foreign
[Music]
best practices when securing software
online is having a zero trust Network
posture firewalls are a critical
component of achieving zero trust
Network posture for your environment
with increased migration of workloads to
Cloud environments more companies are
turning to cloud-first solutions for
their network security needs
Google Cloud provides Cloud firewall a
scalable cloud-first stateful inspection
firewall service with Advanced
protection capabilities
its distributed architecture can enable
micro segmentation through granular
controls enforced at the VM level you
also get an easy to deploy intrusion
prevention service that prevents malware
spyware and command and control attacks
on your network by inspecting both TLS
and non-tls traffic
depending on the scope and complexity of
your Cloud workloads we have multiple
tiers of protection available that each
build off of the lower tier
firewall Essentials firewall standard
and firewall Plus
there are also add-ons which are
available for specific use cases
firewall Essentials the foundational
tier gives you Global and Regional
Network firewall policies micro
segmentation with tags and address
groups
Global Network firewall policies and
Regional Network firewall policies
enable you to group firewall rules into
a policy object applicable to all
regions or specific regions this can
make it easier to apply changes across
your network or specify Regional rules
if regulation or business needs require
it using IAM governed tags along with
network firewall policies provides micro
segmentation and fine-grained control of
your Google Cloud resources
tags are managed centrally with unique
IDs and strict IAM control you can
reference these tags in network firewall
policy rules for titer and uniform
Access Control across your regions and
Network
tags and service accounts are used to
fine-tune the control over incoming and
outgoing traffic on the network level
with address groups we combine multiple
IP addresses and IP ranges into a single
named logical unit
you can reference the same address group
in multiple firewall rules for Ingress
and egress control
this allows the use of automation to
change addresses in group objects
without changing actual firewall rules
many Cloud workflows will need more and
that's why we have firewall standard
firewall standard adds the use of Google
Cloud threat intelligence as well as
fully qualified domain name fqdn objects
and geolocation objects wouldn't it be
great to use the threat intelligence
expertise of the company that is the
internet to so many people
Google Cloud threat intelligence lets
you secure your network by allowing or
blocking traffic based on our threat
intelligence data lists
fully qualified domain name fqdn objects
in firewall policy rules filter incoming
or outgoing traffic from or to specific
domains
based on the traffic direction the IP
address is associated with the domain
names are matched against the source or
destination of the traffic so your
traffic will only come from or go to
trusted resources
geolocation objects in firewall policy
rules filter external ipv4 and IPv6
traffic based on specific Geographic
locations or regions this simplifies the
process of managing traffic to and from
designated countries without the need to
specify individual IP addresses but if
you want even more control firewall plus
is where you will get it firewall plus
gives you the ability to detect and
block threats from your network based on
the latest threat signatures with
security profiles and security profile
groups you can configure your customized
threat detection and prevention logic
security profiles contain the threat
signatures along with corresponding
corrective actions to prevent Network
attacks security profile groups are a
collection of security profiles that are
referenced by the firewall policy rules
to enable deep packet inspection for
incoming or outgoing traffic
firewall endpoint is an organization
level resource that can inspect traffic
too and from VMS deployed in the same
Zone
each firewall endpoint receives
intercepted traffic and performs deep
packet inspection to identify and
prevent any threats
you can deploy firewall endpoints at the
zonal level and then attach it to a VPC
Network where you want to enforce threat
detection and prevention firewall plus
gives you the ability to inspect
encrypted and unencrypted traffic
including both north-south and East-West
traffic you could monitor VM to VM
communication to detect lateral movement
so
if a fully distributed firewall service
with Advanced protection capabilities
micro segmentation and pervasive
coverage to protect your Google cloud
workloads from internal and external
attacks is what you need
Google Cloud firewall is the answer
to find out more information about which
service tier is right for you as well as
pricing and how to use cloud firewall
visit the link on screen and in the
video's description
[Music]